The Invisible Reality: The Wonderful Weirdness of the Quantum World
Good evening.
Thank you.
About a hundred years ago,
a single generation of physicists...
their work caused a radical upheaval in our understanding of the natural world,
our understanding of reality.
And its kind of surprising that, you know, 100 years later,
These insights have not been
widely absorbed
by the general public, but
what is the case is that our
culture has certainly
adopted the language of quantum
mechanics, because for instance,
If we take a look at things
like the quantum
sleeper.
Every loving couple
should have one of these.
It gives protection from biochemical
terrorist attacks,
protection from natural disasters, from kid knappers
stalkers. It's a bullet proof
safe room; and you just have to
sleep inside, sort of like...like...
like dracula. Umm...
What I'd like to
do here tonight, though, is
just go a little bit
further
than the language.
of quantum physics
and try to give you a sense
of the logical progression
of ideas
that led
to this new picture of reality that you saw a little bit
about in the previous video sequence
and then we'll take
up some of the ideas
that physicists are still struggling with
today. So, what I'd like
to do toward that end
is, basically look
at a sequence
of experiments - each one of which
is pretty simple
to describe. Pretty simple
to explain.